Bladesmiths, this
is the strength test--
the hoof chop.
I'm going to be chopping
into these hooves 10 times.
And, remember, this isn't about
what happens to the hooves.
This is what the hooves
do to your blades.
Brad, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I am ready.
I'm just not breathing.
I'm trying to figure out
how to keep it together.
And I want Ben to swing as
hard as he can to make up
for the lightness of my blade.
Oh, my gosh.
Well, Brad, I really like the
construction of your handle.
It was comfortable in my
hand when I was swinging it.
The blade is still
straight, but there
is a little fold right there.
But the rest of it help up well.
Nice job.
Brendan, are you ready?
Sure.
You sound very
sure of yourself.
BRENDAN: I don't think I've ever
been more anxious for somebody
to chop a hoof in half.
I really hope that
forge weld holds
Well, Brendan, I like the
forward heaviness of this
for a chopping
blade, but this thing
is all about what the
hooves do to your knife,
and they kicked it in
the knife, right here.
There's some pretty
significant chipping.
The other issue I
have is the handle
is really small and kind
of hard to hold onto.
Jeff, are you ready?
I've been waiting
four seasons.
I'm ready.
You've been waiting
at the Four Seasons?
That's nice.
Jeff: I'm extremely
nervous at this point.
I can see the chips
in Ben's blade.
Mine could easily
do the same thing.
Well, Jeff, this is
a heck of a chopper.
It's like your knife
didn't even see the hooves.
The one criticism I
have about this blade
is that the handle is
about an inch too long.
It doesn't have a
real comfortable place
to sit and be held.
But very well done.
Nice blade.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
This is the sharpness test.
And what I want to
see in this test
is a nice, clean cut without
any snags or tears in the bag.
Brad, you're up first.
Are you ready?
I'm ready.
You can see the
cuts are pretty clean.
I mean, there's that
nick there, but I don't
think it grabbed anything.
It's a cutter.
It's sharp.
Good job.
All right, Brendan, you're up.
Are you ready?
I'm ready to go.
If it doesn't go
right, that's it.
I'm going home.
Those chips and dings
in your blade, you can see
there's a lot of material
just hung up on them.
I mean the edge is sharp
on either side of that,
but with those missing
places in there,
kind of caught and
pulled through.
It will cut, but it also tears.
All right, Jeff.
Are you ready?
- I'm ready.
So, Jeff, you've got a really,
really stout edge on there.
But there wasn't any resistance
when I made those cuts.
It truly just passed
right through.
The bag speaks for itself.
It's a cutter.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Bladesmiths, the judges have
completed the deliberation
and they've made
a final decision.
It's time for one of
you to leave forge.
Brendan, your blade
did not make the cut.
Doug Marcaida will explain.
Brendan, I commend you
for staying in the game.
But as you can see, your
blade took the most damage
during the strength test.
The process that
you did to harden
and to sharpen your blade
made your edge brittle.
And for that reason,
we have to let you go.
Brendan, please
surrender your weapon.
I'm bummed out
that I don't get
to make the historical weapon.
But this was a
fantastic opportunity.
I'm out of the
way, Brad and Jeff.
May the best man
win, and good luck.